what a very good evening you're watching
the press preview
it's our first look at the front pages
and tonight
we'll check out those headlines with the
chief executive of conservative home
mark wallace
joined by moya lothian mclean the
politics editor of the magazine
galden great to see you both we'll chat
in a second after we've taken a look at
some of those
front pages let's start with the times
it says ministers are expected to
approve
the easing of more restrictions on may
the 17th which will include being able
to hug
friends and family from other households
for the first time in more than a year
the telegraph also focusing on may the
17th with the ban ending on foreign
travel
meaning people can go on holiday abroad
this summer it says
daily mail next launching a campaign on
its front page to help create a memorial
to honor all of the victims of
coronavirus at saint paul's cathedral
tv shows cancelled as harassment claims
grow that's on the front of the guardian
referring to
allegations made against the actor and
movie producer noel clark
at the ft leading with the eurozone
falling into a double
dip recession in the first three months
of the year as the third wave of
coronavirus took hold and the star
pokemon at the prime minister as it's
revealed boris johnson's personal mobile
phone number
has been freely available on the
internet for the last 15 years
the mirror's front page meanwhile
focuses on the duke and duchess of
cambridge boycotting
social media this weekend it's all part
of that campaign against
online racial abuse
and i'm joined tonight by the chief
executive of conservative home mart
wallace and moya lothian
mclean politics editor of the magazine
galdom great to see you both thanks for
being with us this
uh friday evening uh moya let's start
then shall we with um
the front of the times in fact all the
front pages i've got to say really have
got very positive news and it's about
time isn't it
we had something to smile about as we
head into the bank holiday weekend
the headline the times is going with hug
friends
in a fortnight and this is all because
the vaccine rollout is going so well
things look good for may the 17th
yes it's great and it leads with this
amazing picture which is from liverpool
which is a 3 000 revelers in a docs
warehouse and i only wish i was there to
be honest
so the people who turned up to this
event they needed to have a negative
test within 24 hours of attending
and it's part of a two-day event as part
of this pilot scheme which is to test
how they can safely reopen maths events
such as clubbing
um big sporting events etc um it looks
amazing everyone looks so happy
so this is just positive news there's no
there's not more
much else to say about it other than
things are going well for once and the
vaccine rollout is actually ahead of
schedule
which is brilliant i think next week
they're planning to
get onto the people in their 30s which
is amazing
so you know for once we've got this good
news it's great but we have to wait and
see what happens
after this event in liverpool so they'll
be doing a follow-up test five days
after the event they say they're
measuring the air at the event
um but at the moment i think only one in
1 000 people in britain
have covered currently so finally
tentatively things are looking up mark
are you a big clubber fat boy slim is on
tomorrow night i'm being told
izzy well you know i'm not but as much
as it's a privilege to be here
at the press preview i too would rather
be there with three thousand people
just partially just the novelty of
actually being around other people who
aren't part of my immediate family
it almost looks quite surreal doesn't it
i mean it's like looking back it's
something from history really yes i
think we've
all had that experience where you turn
on the tv and you're watching a show
that was obviously recorded
uh before covet and people start kind of
hugging each other and kissing each
other on the cheek and
it it gives you a strange reaction after
the weird conditioning we've all had in
the last year
it's going to be so good just to start
to get rid of all this stuff
and to be able fingers crossed as long
as trials like this
work out as long as the vaccines and
variants continue could continue to go
in the right direction
and they'll be able to start getting
back to our lives and most of all
being social people social beings you
can you know hang out with and enjoy
each other's company
moya something else that's going to
hopefully change on
may the 17th is the ban on holidays and
the daily telegraph
uh says that too is looking very
positive
yeah so before we were warned that
there'd be no
no foreign travel this summer none at
all but now this looks like it might be
rolling back
so they're announcing that there could
there's a ban on foreign travel ending
on the 17th of may
uh we'll be operating under a similar
traffic by system
that we had before so there's the red
list there's the ambulance there's the
green list
um and they'll be you know different
countries will be have different levels
of warning so that will still mean
quarantines that will seem in checks
uh the only thing that i would say could
be a span in the works for this
is there's been warnings recently from
airport officials that border control in
the uk particularly is not prepared
and queues are becoming absolutely
untenable thanks to covert checks which
is obviously something we have to go
through
but the fact it's not sorted out yet and
i would argue probably throughout the
whole of the pandemic
hasn't really been addressed in the way
it should be you know at the start we
didn't have proper cover checks
now we do it's not efficient um so that
poses a bit of a problem
and then there's also questions that
were raised last year when we had the
sort of red list ambulance green list
about the division between the good and
the bad countries that
doesn't necessarily reflect caseload for
example there were countries on the red
list that had
less cases than the us which wasn't put
on that list so
there'll be questions raised about how
certain countries get on certain lists
and whether there might be
a diplomatic influence there as well
yeah you're nodding
along there mark i mean the airline
industry the travel industry
are absolutely on their knees they need
this to happen i think we all need this
to happen but it's not going to be
necessarily plain sailing and there will
be a lot of bureaucracy there'll be
testing there'll be
issues at airports um you know there's
still some way to go
indeed of course you know as we all know
if we do carry on
the fingers cost that we do in
succeeding in this battle against covid
within the uk
the important next stage is making sure
that we don't then
accidentally bring in for example um yet
more
variants we've already gotten a number
of troubling variants in this
country um one of the interesting things
as you were just saying um about the way
in which the industry's been affected i
recently
did an interview with grant shaps and
with some kind of major figures
in the airline industry there's a lot of
stuff going on in the background i think
for example reducing the cost of tests
and you know one of the big things as
well you might be able to fly
but actually you could end up spending
more on tests than you do on flights for
your family at the minute
they're doing a lot to reduce the cost
of testing and it's also going to be
quite interesting
exactly as moya just said to see exactly
how they decide who goes on what list
and
and that includes hints from grant chaps
that we will see a return of the island
scheme that we saw last summer so
some countries that could be on the red
list if there are island destinations
that are part of those countries in a
different situation with covid
they may get an exemption yeah i think
we're here expecting to hear from grant
shap's uh
a news conference sometime next week
let's move on to
uh inside of the times page two of the
times
uh this has been so difficult moyer
hasn't it for people with
relatives with loved ones in care homes
but
finally thank goodness restrictions
there
being eased as well care home residents
will be allowed to visit friends and
families
uh or be outside without having to
isolate when they get back
yeah i think this has been one of the
most
difficult aspects of the pandemic for
people affected
so thankfully finally residents will be
able to leave their care homes to visit
a friend or family member's garden go on
walks
in places such as parks public gardens
beaches they'll need to be accompanied
by a staff member but they won't need to
isolate
um and they can't go inside except to go
to the toilet or to vote but
you know 71 percent of care home
residents now have the vaccination
and one of the things that has been so
hard is the isolation that care home
residents have experienced from the very
beginning
there was that horrific period at the
start of the pandemic when karen
residents you know were being discharged
from hospital
without being tested and that was when
the virus absolutely ran
rampant through care home so that was a
terrible period of fear they've been
locked up
a lot of these people i mean they're
elderly people some of them suffer from
you know memory loss dementia like
conditions
which only worsen when you're separated
from their family and i did a story very
early on the pandemic about how so many
care homes
don't have they didn't have
accessibility in terms of wi-fi they
didn't have internet connectivity
so the things that we even used to keep
in touch with our loved ones you know
these video calls this digital stuff
that just wasn't there the
infrastructure wasn't there and so
many care homes so this is just a
lifeline but i think we should also
remember that for so many people it's
come
really really late and it's it's
devastating yeah it really is
um away from chronovirus mark let's uh
finish this half
with a story on the front of the ft now
this is concerning charles dunstan
uh the founder of cartham warehouse of
course quitting
as downing street steps up what they say
is a cultural cleansing campaign
i think i'm right in saying that it's a
critic from the museum sector who says
yes
a bit of a tasteless term that i
probably wouldn't use on this but this
is part of
an ongoing kind of rumbling story we've
seen the last few months
where they've been a number of these
cases where people who are public
appointees or government appointees or
state appointees to the boards of public
bodies
haven't been reappointed and there seems
to be a kind of
air of shock that the idea that
somebody's already on the board how
could they not be reappointed
for the next term whether it's in
channel 4 or whether in this case in the
museum sector where there's a lot of
debate about um kind of the politics of
culture and museums
i've got to say i i'm frankly i'm glad
to see
the government taking a little bit more
of an active role
in doing what it's meant to be doing
with these appointments which is being
the shareholder or the the
representative in these bodies
of the people who actually fund them who
call who
in whose name these bodies exist which
is
they are public institutions for the
people and
that means that you can't just have an
automatic culture of well you're already
there you should be reappointed
and i think frankly it's good that we're
seeing a bit more challenge i'd like to
see more transparency from government on
how it makes these decisions
but i'm i'm i'm quite glad to see those
and just to kind of
carry on as you were culture coming
going on moya what's your take on this
well i disagree i mean in that story on
the ft front page it's literally a
leading tory says there's an expectation
that members of a board should have a
similar attitude to that of the
government
and i don't think that our public
institutions
should all have to you know the trustees
who are charged with
making sure that these places are
successful that they have this
pluralistic approach
and that their representative should all
have to have a similar attitude to that
of the government
we wouldn't expect other labor
government we shouldn't expect the
victoria government
there should be a diversity of opinion
and approaches and i think more
questions need to be asked about how
people like oliver dowden the culture
secretary
are making these decisions and who
exactly they're penalizing
in ensuring they don't get second terms
you know there's names like mary beard
and the person they're talking about
this story which is animal huck
uh they are they apparently have been
sacked
and they are a trustee whose academic
works advocates
decolonizing the curriculum which is
something that many prominent tories
have been very opposed to in recent
years
so i think we do have to ask more
questions about how these decisions are
made
okay we must leave leave that there uh
thank you both for the moment uh
coming up has the prime minister really
not
changed his phone number for 15 years uh
find out after the break
welcome back part two of the press
preview uh conservative homes
mark wallace is still with me moya i
think we're struggling uh the connection
but uh she oh there she is hello welcome
back uh good to see you both
uh mark let's just uh start with you uh
in the times red wall
blues to deepen in former labour
heartlands all referring to the
elections
next week now despite three
investigations into the flat
refurbishment
potentially a fourth a number of
investigations into the prime minister
um personally as well it seems that
um you know the tories are going to do
really well next week
it certainly seems to be pointing that
way particularly in some of these red
wall areas and remember
the elections next week we've had a big
break in democracy the democratic
process of covert
we've got this huge heap of different
elections wales scotland
mayoralties in london uh in manchester
and liverpool
in teas valley in the west midlands um
as well as the hartlepool by-election
and the council elections
there's a huge amount of riding on it
next week and what this poll
seems to reveal is that the actual the
the detail of the polling is worse for
labor than the headlines so
we've all seen the tories kind of
maintaining their lead
and nationally but if you look at
specifically the red wall it's much
worse for labor than that because
actually labour is piling up votes in
london for example in some parts of the
south and some
a few parts of their former heartlands
but in those places
in 2019 fell it helped to make this big
majority of 80 seats
it seems like labour then he has slipped
further behind among some of those
former
lifelong labour voters who they've lost
who they were really hoping to win back
moya in december labour had a four point
lead over conservatives this week labour
is 11
points behind why is that do you think
i mean there was a poll that came out i
think about three weeks ago
done in the red wall heartlands which
seemed to
pin a lot of the blame sadly on zakir
stammer himself
and the fact he's not cutting through
with the voters there so
for several reasons it appeared i think
voters said that they didn't know what
he stood for
uh they felt like he hadn't led enough
um
so i know that kier has been very
cautious over the last year because it's
difficult to lead as an opposition
during a pandemic he would argue
and i know that the parties argued this
but it seems like it's not enough so
there needs to be a serious
rethink on the part of the top labour
brass about where they go from here
i know in this time story there's a
senior mp quoted who is on the labour
left we should say
that stamina should consider stepping
down if it becomes clear he's not making
enough progress in these red wall areas
um i don't know if we're even there yet
but i know that whatever the party is
doing it seems like they're throwing a
lot of stuff at the wall
but they're still not making the
connection with the labor heartlands and
i think it's very telling that recently
they let go the entirety of their
community organizing unit
who will be finishing in may whereas it
seems like what they need is that
community organizing
in these heartlands because something is
not connecting uh moya i'm gonna leave
that there because i just want to do the
last 10 seconds mark on boris's phone
number tell me about
well yes this this is the revelation in
the last couple of days that actually
you could potentially find
boris's phone number online or an old
press release
i think that's probably the case for an
awful lot of mps the gold thing that you
don't want to give up in westminster as
in so many walks of life
is your number because it's how people
can get hold of you and now at last
he's been forced to change